[Music]
one of the things that happened in
recent years was that as globalization
which is kind of a catch-all term for
what was happening in terms of increased
economic interdependence growing trade
technology technological penetration of
many industries and automation and all
those things and everything the internet
did was that because all of those things
integration of the world countries
coming closer together technology
because all those to the internet
because all those things kind of have a
a nice ring to them a kind of moral glow
the people who were ardent champions of
globalization always spoke of
globalization as though it were not just
an ideology or a process but kind of
truth and light and that anybody who
along the way whether in the steel towns
of Eastern Ohio or in you know large
swaths of this country where this kind
of revolution actually meant much of
choppier employment and precarious wages
or in large swaths of the world where
the increasing pace of life meant that
yes you might make a lot of money but
then industries would kind of vanish as
fast as they came anybody complaining
about what globalization was doing to
them was rich planed by these defenders
of globalization that you know you're
you're being provincial what do you not
like the coming together of Nations are
you against the peoples of the world
connecting are you against technology
and the empower you don't want people to
be empowered and there was this way in
which anybody who was raising alarm
bells over the 3040 year period that I'm
talking about here was cast as being
narrow-minded provincial and small
hearted and I think that is one of the
reasons our antenna in the elite
Citadel's of American life failed to
detect so many incoming true
missions about the modern world actually
not working for most people and and
perhaps failed to detect some of the
shifts that led on the left to Bernie
Sanders winning as much as he did
despite all the obstacles for him as a
candidate and Donald Trump successfully
winning because I think we didn't really
understand how much people meant it when
they were telling us all along that the
world wasn't the new world wasn't
working for them and I didn't matter how
morally superior the high-tech
interdependent world you know it didn't
matter how much house appeared people
thought it was
[Music]